hey y'all movie retrospective time
and here's the one that won the patreon
poll this week by quite a large margin
sort of a forgotten movie from the 90s
not my favorite decade for horror but
this one's it's not too bad
the thing about this one it's called the
relic
and it's from 1997. and
i was interested to see this one because
when i was scrolling through
all of the streaming services and i saw
that this one was on hulu
and i remembered that back in the day
like back in
like the early 2000s i read this novel
because if you guys don't know this is
actually the first of um
you know douglas preston and lincoln
child they wrote all those books with
that fbi agent agent prender
agent prendergast i think is his name
and he's kind of a recurring character
and all those books i haven't read all
of them but i read like
a selection of them and they're actually
really good and this movie is based on
uh the first one that had ancient agent
prendergast in it even though he is not
a character in the movie for whatever
reason
so and then i was thinking to myself i
was like so i read the book and it was
really good i'm like wait did i see this
movie
and i was like you'd think that i would
have watched it because i read the book
but i don't think i ever saw it
i think i'm getting it confused with
mimic yeah
um because that came out i don't know i
don't remember but it was like around
the same
time yeah a couple years before i think
and uh so and it was kind of like a
monster movie as well
and so i kind of feel like was that king
or middle torah honestly it was
guillermo del toro but i could be
totally wrong about that
but i remember seeing that when i read
that book too and so i think
so i couldn't remember that this one i
was just kind of like oh i saw mimic i
don't think i saw this one because when
i watched this one i did not remember
it i didn't so i don't think i ever saw
this one this is a weird flick i mean
it's a it's a monster movie yeah a
higher end monster movie
it sometimes it kind of had
a feeling like it was verging on
jurassic park
in a certain way it had cg in it it was
pretty good
quality except for a couple shots i was
like nah that's pretty bad but
it was just a weird movie um it could
have been a great movie
but as it is because of the edit it's
just
it's just it's a strange movie it's it's
it's okay
um it could have been great it had
greatness
in it it was shot beautifully had a real
good score
the acting was really good there's
something about the edit of this movie
especially the last
one third of it is very muddy
it's the the edits are so fast and so
quick during some of the action
sequences and everything's so dark you
can't really tell what's going on you
start to
not care what's happening it's not real
clear what
what the monster did but what was
interesting was kind of like it's a
detective
story too yeah the detective has
gotten onto this weird case and you
think it might have something to do with
voodoo magic
and then as it evolves you realize it
has something to do with kind of like
genetic mutations
and but like really quick ones yeah real
fast
it's coming out of the amazon jungle so
it's like a sci-fi horror
thriller and like like you said i think
a lot of people did kind of compare it
to
um to jurassic park and actually they
did
well you know not so much but that's
just it felt like it was trying to build
more than anything because like the book
a lot of people said it's you know this
is kind of like michael crichton for
people that don't really like michael
crichton yeah
um because i actually the uh preston and
child's books i actually kind of like
those better than michael crichton's
books
for whatever reason and i especially
liked the ones with agent prendergast
which i think is really weird because so
they made this movie
which had the fbi agent in it like i
said who's a recurring character in a
lot of their books
and i don't know why they would make an
adaptation and leave out
what was essentially the main character
yeah i mean yes
um they have the other licensing maybe
well i don't know but i mean if they're
gonna make if they're gonna make an
adaptation
they have to pay for the rights so you'd
think that they would want
yeah maybe some of the later books and
they're just kind of like i don't know
what the deal was
but it's like agent prendergast is such
a great character
um he's almost kind of like he's this
weird like southern
uh fbi agent and he's real like uh he's
almost like a vampiric
you know what i mean like he's real
scrawny and pale and he's but he's like
a super genius like sherlock holmes or
something
and he's just like this really great
character and i don't know why they
wouldn't put it in there
uh but you know that's neither here nor
there but what they did do
is uh tom sizemore is in this and he's
playing uh you know essentially the
investigator character
uh you know so so what you have if you
guys haven't seen this movie
is that at the very beginning you get
kind of a prologue
where this dude who's like an
anthropologist and he's down in brazil
right and he's down in brazil
studying some you know tribes and
they give him this stuff like some kind
of drink or something and it makes him
like freak out
kind of like ayahuasca yeah something
like that like he starts seeing [ __ ] or
whatever and then
he's wigging out um you know i have
these crates and i have to get them off
the ship
uh but you don't know why you know what
i mean so then they kind of go to
uh the chicago natural history museum
where they actually did shoot this at
least the exteriors and
some of the inside and uh these
crates have arrived but the
anthropologist john whitney
uh has not arrived but no one's super
worried about it because they figured oh
he's out in the field and you know we
haven't heard from for a while but
that's not that unusual so nobody
thought anything was weird
so inside these crates they find like
one of them has this kind of like statue
like an idol
type type of thing that he had sent that
looks kind of like a little monster or
whatever
and then the other one doesn't seem to
have any it looks like it just had
leaves in it
but they're just kind of like well was
something packed in the leaves it was
like maybe not
because it was like nailed shut when it
got here so obviously nobody like
nothing
busted out or whatever so they can't
like figure it out
so as it goes on um
you know that something like i said it's
a monster movie so you know that there's
a monster loose in this museum
but the people don't know that right so
people start turning up dead
the first of them is like a security
guard right poor dude is like sitting on
the john
uh enjoying a joint on his break as one
does
and uh an unseen monster pulls him out
the thing
pulls his head off like the cap off a
two liter
and uh sucks his brain out and eats part
of it
yeah um now initially they think this is
a person doing this
uh you know probably a really big person
this is the problem this is part of the
problem with the movie
it you don't see this monster
very well or clearly at all until the
very end
and it's too late they should have
showed they should have showed you this
monster
way early in the movie there should have
been a lot more of it
but because because of the editing and
maybe budget it comes off as a detective
movie
that has a monster in the end of it and
to me it just didn't work
it should have been more like alien well
it's interesting because the director of
this who was peter hyams who's also a
cinematographer so he's like generally
the cinematographer of zen movies
he's made a [ __ ] ton of movies he's made
he made 2010.
uh he did uh some steve uh not stephen's
goal he does i like
2002. yeah who's the other [ __ ] uh
fondo
yeah john damn he did a time comp he did
uh sudden death he did like some of the
other ones he's done like a lot of
big movies and uh like i said he's
usually the cinematographer on them the
cinematography on this is really nice
but
the main main complaint that i see with
a lot of people and honestly i watch a
lot of horror channels
and a lot of horror dudes uh actually do
like this movie and think it was like
underrated
but a lot of them do point out it's
really
[ __ ] dark and not dark as in oh
that's so [ __ ] up
dark isn't you can't see anything now
what ended up happening with this now
that was a deliberate choice by peter
hyams he's like i wanted to make it
he's like i wanted to kind of explore
you know the relationship of like the
shadow and he really liked the idea
and he really liked the idea of alien
where it was just kind of like this
really dark and everybody's kind of like
that it's really claustrophobic and he
really wanted to explore that
now what i've heard and i don't know if
this is the case but
when it was in playing in the theater
you can actually see it a lot better
you know what i'm saying because of just
that you're in a dark dude but then when
it was uh
transferred to vhs and then to dvd they
didn't color correct it properly
uh and so it was too dark now i will say
we watched it on hulu as i said and i
imagine i don't know if they would spend
like a [ __ ] ton of money to restore this
because
you know it did make money uh but it
wasn't like a massive hit and i think
it's kind of
mostly been forgotten about these days
so i don't know if they would have
caught
would have like taken the time to
brighten it up or
you know if so if you're gonna watch it
it is really really dark and sometimes
it's so dark that you can't tell what
the [ __ ] is going on
but you but you know when i when i was
reading something about
the director and like what he was trying
to do with it i could see what he was
trying to do
and nobody complained about it when it
was in the theater so i'm assuming that
that was more like a transfer
issue that it was you know that it just
came out too dark when they transferred
it
but um yeah and i thought it was all the
all the action part of it or the
adventure or monster part of it was
towards the end of it and it really
should have been it should have happened
a lot faster
and over a longer period of time and i
think the monster should have been more
of a character
in the way that the alien was a
character
yeah you should have been able to talk
or something or you
should have been able to see it and kind
of establish
a relationship with the audience because
for most of the movie it's just
kind of an idea that there's something
bad out there
yeah it's like you kind of see his claw
and you kind of see like really quick
yeah uh you know he's over there in the
shadows or whatever now and like i said
that was also a deliberate choice
because
peter hym's like i said he's a big fan
of alien he's a big fan of jaws
uh and he's a big fan of like monster
movies like that and he's like and i
like
that you don't see the monster like in
jaws or whatever for a really long time
so that when you do see him at the end
it's like a lot more impact
but i think that he did like leave it a
little bit too long because i will say
that the monster in this which was
designed by stan winston
looks great i really really like the
monster design i like the way the
monster looks
um i think it's called a kathoga yeah um
it
oh hold on one second the reason why
because i want to back up and address
it in alien one
making you wait to see the monster
worked
in that movie because of the visuals of
that movie
yeah you already saw the alien
spacecraft you saw the space jockey
already
the interior shots of the damn spaceship
alone
would satisfy you this is just shots of
of brazil and um chicago
so it's not taking you to another world
right you got to see something different
you know little flashes of things aren't
going to be that satisfying in this
context
you should have saw that monster early
on and done something real creative with
it
it's a pretty cool looking monster
but it was cooler back in the day it's
like
a lizard mixed with a damn
what is it a jaguar like a beetle or a
beetle and a jaguar and a human
or something it's just weird it has
teeth
on it yeah maybe i guess those are
supposed to be lizard teeth
his head looked like the damn logo from
motorhead
look just like that with a little bit of
beetle mixed into it
on a giant lizard body that could climb
up the walls
it wasn't a bad monster design um
the cg on most of the shots of it looked
really good especially for the day
but it would stand up today the only
shots that
where it kind of sucked is there's a
shot of it two or three times it shows
a shot of a woman running and behind her
is the damn monster chasing her and it's
on fire kind of like the indiana jones
running from the ball
yeah shot and that thing looks like [ __ ]
on fire it doesn't it looks
it looks fake as [ __ ] no it
and it burned for a long time kind of
inexplicably maybe it was because it was
covered in chemicals
yeah i think that was yeah she had like
made kind of like a molotov cocktail
type of thing with all the uh
and it didn't seem to react to the fire
too much chemicals didn't care that it
was on fire it was just kind of weird
well you know what too is that whole end
sequence with the monster chasing her
and then her getting in the tank and
then the monster blowing up everything
that was actually not in the original
script what ended up happening this
movie was actually supposed to come out
before it came out like a year before or
a few months before it was supposed to
come out in 1996
but they showed it to audiences and the
audiences liked it but they were just
kind of like well we
the end needs more pizzazz they didn't
like they needed more big explosion
you know what i mean yeah um you know
they're because what they said they said
we want everybody to like cheer when the
monster dies like whoa they got him or
whatever
and there's like so at the end she just
kind of like sets it on fire and then
she gets away and it ends
um but so the audiences are just kind of
like oh okay
so they're like okay well how about we
make it so it chases her a little bit
more and it's on fire and then it
explodes
and then the audience test audiences
seem to like that better so but that so
that wasn't the original
ending that was actually put on after
the test audiences
wanted a more like a bigger ending i
remember how things went
this movie was made for an audience that
kind of came out of the 80s and then
went through the 90s and they're still
alive today
hollywood had a hard time still to this
day has a hard time
selling movies to certain generations
because the generation was maturing
along with hollywood and things would
kind of get
old you know during the time the 90s had
rolled around the 80s action movie
um template was pretty stale
so they had to come up with new stuff to
satisfy that audience
in the 90s the idea of an off of a
of an audience i think going wow they
got the monster and [ __ ]
the audience was already older and kind
of jaded by that time you're never going
to have that same reaction like when
they blew up jaws
yeah you know what i mean i was a little
kid in the theater they [ __ ] flew up
to jaws
[Laughter]
it was a more it was simpler times you
know it wasn't competing against video
games and youtube and everything it's
just
yeah everyone's just such a cynical
background everyone's very cynical that
imagery does not make an impact on
people too much anymore they've seen
everything
seeing [ __ ] fantastic imagery even on
your phone
was something that was just undreamed of
even in the 90s
they were just you know so
really the only thing that's effective
nowadays is story and it's real hard to
have
millions of movies coming out of
hollywood or thousands of them per year
and all of them having excellent stories
they just can't generate it
you know yeah and the talent isn't there
well yeah and like i said a few
it's always kind of like that and like i
said this this movie it's not a bad
movie by any stretch the imagination is
pretty entertaining
um it got so so reviews when it came out
like uh
cisco and ebert really liked it for some
reason they just said yeah it was really
entertaining
one thing that i will give it props for
is that
i feel like in the 90s you know there
was a lot of horror movies that came out
there were some r-rated ones but they
were mostly aimed toward teenagers
this one was still r-rated and it's
actually pretty gory you did get to see
the monster like pull
dude's head off and it's like there's
brains and gore and stuff like that
um and the fact that they made an
r-rated horror movie with
adult characters like in an actual like
adult job like it was in a museum
and it was all had to do with like you
know there was some museum intrigue like
people trying to get grants and stuff
that was kind of going on in the
background
and then it kind of had like the
scientific uh thing of where the monster
came from and it was like
mutating really fast you know what i
mean i guess it started out really small
because she found that one thing and
then she found out it was like had this
much dna from a lizard and this much
or it was a gecko and this much dna from
like a certain kind of beetle
and then they found out that it was like
that was kind of like the big uh reveal
at the end was that it actually
had 40 something percent human dna um
and then you find out that the
the anthropologist at the beginning of
the movie he was freaking out about the
crates john whitney
um i guess he had sort of like
genetically like evolved
into this monster or he had like somehow
yeah it was taking his dna or whatever
yeah it probably is clear if you go back
and re-watch it and pay a lot of
attention but i don't think the average
person in the audience back then
would have really given a [ __ ] enough to
really figure that part of it out
they're just like yeah okay
i remember we just [ __ ] accepted [ __ ]
yeah well yeah a lot of the science and
especially if you're watching like just
a fun monster movie that has science
fiction it's just
you can go with a little bit of hand
wavy kind of yeah that sounds reasonable
enough right you know what i mean
as long as it's not so outlandish that
it like takes you out of the story
i think i think part of the re part of
the strength of the movie also kind of
was
part of its downfall and i think you
mentioned it it was adults
doing adult jobs it was supposed to be
very believable
and and grounded in reality which that
kind of took
away of some of the [ __ ] fantasy that
you could have gone with you could have
made this a lot wilder
and probably a lot more entertaining if
you didn't try to keep it and
grounded in reality constantly like
imagine if this was an arnold
schwarzenegger style
action movie like predator or even
though that was pretty grounded in
reality in certain ways
or just something like running ban where
you're just fighting a monster
yeah you could do some funny [ __ ] and
you know have big epic
scenes and it really does you know it's
just fun to watch it could
that would probably have gotten a better
response from the audience
you know having gone through the 90s i
did not see this movie in the 90s
i didn't either but had you asked me had
i
seen them back then and you asked me
which one was better this one or mimic i
just said mimic was better
i think that's pretty much the consensus
i mean i saw mimik a long time ago but i
remember
that one being like pretty decent yeah i
didn't see this one at the even though
this one has a bigger scope
it has a much bigger scope and it felt
like i had a bigger budget
and visually it was probably more
impressive this wouldn't have stuck with
me
mimick kind of did for a while yeah some
of the ideas behind mimic
a human-sized damn cockroach that could
pretend to be a human
that's [ __ ] that was something that
was kind of interesting [ __ ] up
that kind of that's like my worst night
that idea was kind of intriguing
to especially when i didn't know what it
was when i was first watching it it
looked like some kind of spooky man
but it turned out it was just really a
carapace of a [ __ ] roach
gigantic cockroach at which point i
would have been like no
just impersonating a human a roach that
can impersonate a human that's like
horrifying
they couldn't talk but you see they they
reveal that this thing is like 40
human dna man that gave you license
right there to make it talk
it could have talked later because i
think the whole thing i think it was
evolving
throughout the course of the movie had
it talked it could have been
uh um a character and then you could
have done some [ __ ] like i don't know
something like maybe out of the keep
remember that movie the keep we're gonna
have to review that yeah
how to get a good copy i like that i
haven't seen it forever i was looking
for it on a streaming service the other
day but i couldn't find one if i
couldn't find it eventually you find the
damn monster and it's like a jewish
golem or something wasn't it a golem
or it was yeah i thought it was
something like something like that and
it could talk
i haven't seen that and it was it was
hell bent on getting vent
killing off all the nazis it was pretty
cool
and it could talk that [ __ ] added a
whole new dimension to it
i mean you got well i mean you really
gotta that's treading a fine line when
you're
having to monster that talks yeah i mean
depending on what kind of monster you
have to know how to play it right
because it was only 40 humans so it it
would have been
talking but its motivations would have
been inhuman
inhuman type stuff and its thinking
would have been kind of inhuman which
that would
you could have fun writing dialogue for
that i remember like i said i
i read the book of this a long time ago
i remember liking the book a lot because
i really really like
books that are set in museums and i
really like particularly horror
that said in museums because the museum
is like kind of inherently creepy anyway
um and i love that actually well peter
hiams
uh you know he didn't write the book
obviously but he was excited to do this
adaptation because he grew up across the
street from the
uh natural history museum in new york
and he always had like recurring
nightmares about being
being locked in there overnight and like
the big squid you know if you've been
been there and you see the big squid and
the whale thing that buff
up on the ceiling and like of that
attacking him and stuff so he was really
excited to do this
book because he's like oh it's like my
worst nightmare it'll be really awesome
but i just um i don't know it's just
kind of
the book was really good but i feel like
and i like the concept of the monster
that kind of comes there in the crate
and then they don't really know what it
is
exactly and then it's you know it's kind
of
evolving over the course of the thing
and i like and i respect the decision
that he had he's like i want to make
this like really dark and shadowy that's
cool
um you know i want to make it so you
don't see the monster that much because
it'll have more impact at the end which
i think is a good idea generally
um i just think he waited too long on
this one and like i said the monster
actually does look cool
and i really like that they that they
didn't shy away from the gore i mean
like i said they actually do show
people's heads getting pulled off and
you know so it is like a fairly gory
like horror movie
which is nice because a lot of them you
know they try to stick to pg-13 which is
lame compared to other this is a mutant
monster movie yeah compared to other
mutant monster movies like prophecy or
something it's all it's
it's head and shoulders above that yeah
but when it comes to like
and i would say mimic is another mutant
monster movie mimics
i would say a little bit better yeah um
the best
mutant monster movie that i could
recommend was one called splice
that's how i would do it remember wasn't
it called splice was that the one where
the guy
were where they were the daughter and
the thing and adrian brody
[ __ ] the daughter alien whatever it's
not a daughter and it's not an alien
it's not an alien but it's yeah it they
worked at some kind i got to see it
again i need to get a good copy of it
but i thought i thought it was a [ __ ]
badass idea it was some
people that worked at a genetic lab and
a guy kinda
i think they did want a child at first
but they just made one
it was mostly human but not really it
had a bunch of other stuff i think it
had
some insect stuff and some plant dna and
everything yeah
i've only seen it once but they brought
it back it looked like a human girl kind
of but it grew
to adulthood real quickly and didn't it
change into a
male at some point yeah yeah and there's
a reason why that had it was
because it it was i think that had
something to do with it wasn't it part
mollusk or something where it was
something that could
change sex under certain which some fish
and stuff
yeah it was bizarre they bring it back
it kind of looks a little bit like an
alien but it was female it was kind of
sexy
turns out later he was having sex with
it but it was
it was real friendly you know and it
wasn't human
and he [ __ ] it over and it got pissed
and turned into a male
and it was [ __ ] deadly as a male to
try to get revenge on him for breaking
his heart
i guess it'd be a good way to describe
it he got jealous over his girlfriend
over his wife
yeah and so it was two females competing
for a while it was good
it was good that that one because that
was
that was a mutant movie that it seemed
kind of plausible and it was kind of
scary because
it was a monster but it was it was cute
and he had sex with it
that that that's conscious pretty weird
that's a pretty weird concept
well not a lot of movies would go there
yeah yeah
and they fell in love with him yeah and
then it got pissed
you know that's like which that was
mostly human i think but it had a bunch
of other stuff it mixed in with it
and they weren't and they did it
illegally nobody's supposed to know that
they had it well yeah it's a little
unethical yeah and they were hiding it
out into shack and it became a teenager
just in a couple weeks remember
it was doing stuff a teenage girl would
do and getting hit it got pissed
and it made a move on the dude and he
he's like all right let's get it on
you know whatever yeah that came back
and bite him in the ass
yeah well that was a good movie it just
seemed a lot more plausible
because i think a dude would do that oh
yeah i'm sure i'm sure most of them
would
yeah well it had agency
yeah you know so he's he's just like
okay i guess it is a woman
so he's he's that's enough close enough
yeah that's weird it's weird but
probably could have gone the other way
around if it was a woman
and she made a male creature like that
if that [ __ ] was hot she'd
probably let it hit
and that's and then what kind of child
would you have you see this
is the crazy [ __ ] that really should be
in these kind of sci-fi movies
it should just kind of tread on the edge
of [ __ ]
a [ __ ] you know of morality you know
well like i said that was like some
like well like a couple years back uh
guillermo del toro made shape of water
which is about a woman having sex with a
fish
man okay yeah yeah yeah yeah like that
that might happen what comes out a bunch
of tadpoles
and then what are the two much easier
than human babies yeah and then what do
the tadpoles do
yeah do you keep them in a fish tank do
they get out what happens to them when
they grow big
what do they eat do they try making
moves on humans does it become like
humanoids from the deep
see that's some scary [ __ ] that we
[ __ ] need to ask ourselves
that's the way i'm thinking about it you
know animal kingdom stuff and you're
you're just another one of the animals
in the kingdom yeah we'll see
they're they're bringing you down to
that level yeah well yeah so so when you
put it that way
you know a movie like this which is just
like like you said it's basically just a
standard
monster yeah it's a standard monster um
you know yeah they've
you know they introduced the concept of
like this really really quick
evolution which is a good concept but
they don't do a great deal with it
no yeah there was no set it was part man
yeah so where's the sexual angle
and he was and and the thing about it i
didn't even talk what it ate
the reason why i was pulling everyone's
like popping everyone's heads off was
because it ate
like straight out of your hypothalamus
yeah um so it would have to pop your
head off and then it would like
it would like suck your brain out or
whatever and then it would just like
leave the
brain there like a [ __ ] empty caprice
on i mean there was one there was one
scene where it runs up on
on a on a good looking woman and it
considers
it licks her licks are like and then is
it going to kill her because it had
killed a bunch of other people and
killed some dogs and it didn't kill her
but come on man that's a cop out
well i thought for a second because i
didn't know if it was like it didn't
kill her because this was at the end it
was penelope and miller's character
who was kind of like the main character
name so she's also she's a biologist i
think
and uh her name is margot green and so i
didn't know
if the monster didn't kill her just
because it was the end and she had to be
the hero and kill it
or if it or if the human part of that
remembered her
yeah because when it was a dude it knew
that she was that's what i'm getting at
right they even knew all the way back in
the 20s was that the 20s or 30s the king
kong
king kong was after the women yeah see
there was
the the idea that the monster is after
the one the the
humans for sexual or romantic purposes
that's adds to the [ __ ]
to the to the to the horror yeah you
know what i mean
and he just walked away from that that
[ __ ] monster should have said
i'm a mate with this that goes all the
way back man that goes all the way back
to humanoids from the deep king kong
[ __ ] that goes back to all of them you
know it does yeah
yeah and then they even reversed it with
mighty joe young mighty joe young was
the good king kong and he had a human
girlfriend
remember that get him mighty joe you
kind of know what the hell
is this what's going on between this
woman and this and this in this gorilla
you know just there's i'm telling you
there's a whole sub-genre of porn
yeah what's going on with this girl why
is this why does this woman love this
gorilla so much
you know he's the hero because he
doesn't talk back
you know but
i'm just [ __ ] wrong because he's big
well i mean because gorillas are kind of
like big but they're also sort of gentle
yeah yeah so yeah and like i said they
can't talk so hey man that's always a
plus
they got a they got a young male gorilla
down in the tokyo zoo that has all a
huge fan base
nothing but these japanese girls [ __ ]
sending him love letters and taking
pictures of him saying he's the
most handsome gorilla in the world and
[ __ ] he's standing there [ __ ] showing
off he knows he's [ __ ] he knows that
those
japanese girls were loving on him he's
sitting there just trying to be as
handsome as he possibly can and
[Laughter]
yeah just basking in it basking in glory
you gotta hold things on youtube about
that damn tokyo's most hand japan's most
handsome gorilla what's that girl's name
i can't remember what his name is
uh but yeah so so like i said if you
didn't see it i think the best things
about this movie i really like the
monster design which like i said with
stan winston
mostly practical effects especially when
you see them close up
uh when the movie when the monster is
like running around at cgi
but actually the cgi even for 1997
actually looks really decent except for
the end when it's on fire and running
then it looks super fake um so you know
that's that's kind of not the technology
wasn't ready yet it wasn't yet it was
just the 90s and well like i said that
was tacked on later because
you know the end wasn't explosive enough
right um i really like uh tom sizemore
in this
as uh the lieutenant or whatever like
the detective
uh digosta i think his name is he's
really good in it
uh clayton rohner is in this which i
always like to see him he's not in
enough movies he was in april fool's day
and some other uh
horror movies back in the day and i
always like uh seeing him in there he
doesn't have a huge part but he's good
in it
um you know it's i just feel like
there's a good move in here somewhere
it's it's just it's dark it's hard to
tell what's going on in the
last third when the monster is chasing
everybody through this
closed down museum um and
you know the you can't and the and the
edit is so quick that a lot of times you
can't really tell what's happening
um so that's kind of like a little bit
but it's totally worth watching
especially
if you liked the novel um i don't like i
said i don't know why they left agent
prendergast out because he's like the
main character in the book and he's like
a really good character
but whatever it's you know what i mean i
didn't know like they could have started
a whole franchise with that dude because
they've
cause uh what's their faces like they
wrote like a whole bunch of books with
that character
and the ones i've read are actually
really good so i don't know why they
haven't like adapted those yet but
whatever
but yeah it's on uh hulu at the moment
if you want to watch it might be on some
other streaming services as well you
know it's not
fantastic but it's like decent it's
worth watching if you like
uh monster movies so you know i guess
that uh will do it for this
movie retrospective and we will see you
guys on the next one
bye